so this big hurricane is on its way to
Florida this is definitely this is this
is definitely a boy who cried wolf
problem every now every time now with
the Hurricanes because every year every
year without fail we're told about some
monster historic storm that will have a
devastating impact and potentially kill
hundreds of people and then you know The
Drudge Report if you go the judge report
right now it's just it's just one story
after another it's a very dramatic thing
which is what he always does with
hurricanes and then most of the time it
comes and goes
and it does some damage but nothing
historic occurs and that's the end of it
and they're saying the same thing right
now with this one potentially and and
who knows you know maybe it will be true
I'm not a meteorologist so if you live
in one of the potential areas affected
by the hurricane hurricane don't listen
to what I'm don't make any decisions
based on what I'm saying I mean in
general in life don't make decisions
based on what I say but especially with
this because I'm not making any
predictions about what will or won't
happen I'm just saying that we have to
stop turning every hurricane into
Armageddon because then it makes it
impossible to actually distinguish the
serious threats from the unserious ones
I remember I lived I lived in a coastal
town well near coastal I lived very
close to a coastal town a few miles from
the coast for for several years in my
early 20s and one of those years we had
a big hyped hurricane headed for us I
don't remember which one what what's the
name of it was but I remember this you
know the hype leading up to it very well
and I especially remember having this
emotional conversation with my then
girlfriend now wife and she was trying
to convince me to you know we were on
the phone she was trying to convince me
to leave to evacuate and to go stay with
her at her mother's house because it's
gonna be so dangerous she was afraid I
was gonna die in the hurricane and and
and I said you know I I couldn't do that
because I had to work and I mean my town
hadn't technically been evacuated
because it was more inland so you know
and I had and I had a job and everything
so I was going to stay and so I told her
I
said no I must stay my love fear not
words that effect it's not exactly what
I said but something like that and that
night when the hurricane was supposed to
a supposed to hit in the middle of the
night and so I I slept yeah they said on
the news don't you don't to be near
windows so I slept like behind the couch
and in a sleeping bag away from the
windows and I was just expecting I had
canned goods and had flashlights and I
had whiskey side all the stuff you need
to get through the hurricane and I was
expecting to wake up the next morning
and it would be like the movie the road
where you'd have bands of cannibals
patrolling the streets and you know just
just utter devastation and I woke up the
next morning and all the damage
consisted of there were some there was
there was there were a lot of leaves
that had blown onto my porch which I had
to sweep those away that was annoying
and there was an especially large twig
that had fallen onto the hood of my car
and you know actually scratched it a
little bit that was the extent of the
damage after all of this hype my point
here is that coverage of hurricanes
I think the coverage is extremely
irresponsible all the time now because
there's no attempt to be reasonable or
to be restrained and the effect is that
everyone treats hurricane coverage now
like entertainment and nobody takes it
seriously and that's a dangerous
situation because sometimes these
hurricanes actually are bad
we know that really bad hurricanes do
happen they don't happen every year I
mean every year we don't have a historic
hurricane unlike what we're told by the
media and by climate change activists
which we'll get to that in a second we
don't have them every year but sometimes
they do happen it's just that now if you
if you live in one of these areas and
you're trying to figure out is this
something like that or is this gonna be
a dud I mean to leave your home and your
work and everything behind that's not
it's not a sort of an automatic thing
it's a decision you have to make and and
so I don't I don't I don't envy the
people who live in these towns where
hurricanes happen because how do you how
are you supposed to know anymore when
every single hurricane is treated this
way so who knows maybe this will be one
of those situation Dorian which concerns
me I just mentioned briefly here
Bloomberg has a report about an added
threat of this store
you see Miami which is maybe in line for
the for the hurricane like a lot of
cities these days is infested with
scooters people go around on these
scooters because they're too lazy to
walk and too cheap to take an uber so
they go around on these scooters
everywhere and so now some officials are
worried that the Hurricanes are gonna
sweep up these scooters and turn them
into projectiles and you're gonna have
you know people dying from flying
scooters all over the place which would
be like the weirdest sharknado sequel
ever maybe there will be sharks on the
scooters that would be that's an idea
actually for for a movie who knows
anything is possible all right before we
go any further and as I said speaking of
climate change activists there's this
one particular climate change activists
so you've probably seen on your TV in
the last few days but we're gonna talk
about about her and about that in a
second but first I want to tell you
about our good friends over at dynatrap
you know I've been telling you about
dynatrap all summer long and just as the
summer is winding down that doesn't mean
they don't have to worry anymore about
bugs and insects inside your home in
fact as the weather cools down you know
those bugs outside are gonna look for
warmer more inviting conditions and
that's where they come into your home
into your home that's this is your house
we're talking about you didn't invite
them in yet they come and that's why
we'd like to thank our sponsors over at
dynatrap dynatrap is the leading
manufacturer of outdoor mosquito and
insect traps and now they come up with a
solution for indoor pests that is the
dynatrap fly light the dynatrap fly
light works day and night to attract and
trap flies fruit flies mosquitoes other
pesky insects and it really does work I
was you know we were on vacation last
week and I was there with with my
in-laws and my brother and sister-in-law
this is true they were actually we were
actually having a conversation about the
dynatrap fly flight and because they've
you know they've listened to the podcast
and they they've heard me talking about
it and they said does it really actually
work are you just saying I said no it
really does work it is great that was an
actual conversation that took place so
dynatrap fly light look this thing it's
a it's a it's a light you plug it in
and it attracts the the Flies and then
and all the other insects and it gets
rid of them and it really is as easy as
that get yours at dynatrap calm that's
Dyn ATR AP calm and to the promo code
walsh and receive 15% off any of their
products dynatrap the safe silent simple
solution to household insect control
okay so Greta foon Berg or thundered
through Berg I know I haven't said
anything about this story up until now
because I don't care that much but there
is one aspect of it that really grinds
my gears as Peter Griffin might say
Greta is a 16 year old climate change
activists from Sweden who was invited to
speak in front of a UN Assembly in New
York for some reason I mean of all the
people in the world who maybe could
speak on the issue of climate change
they said let's get this 16 year old in
there okay but she didn't want to fly
here because of the carbon emissions
from airplanes so instead she embarked
on a day's long journey across the ocean
on a sailing yacht which sounds like a
lot of fun I you know I would love to do
that I'm a fan of boats in the water but
you know I don't really have access to a
sailing not I don't know about you and
it was a big public to do a lot of
height for the media of course hype
because that's all the media does is
hype things hype that was helped by the
fact that Greta makes disparaging
comments about Donald Trump here and
there and so the media loves that and
she finally got here on her yacht she
spoke to reporters yesterday let's watch
let's watch a little bit of that it's
strange everyone always asked me about
Donald Trump
but I mean my message for him is just
listen to the science and he obviously
doesn't do that so I mean I as I always
say to this question if if no one has
been able to convince him about the
climate crisis the the urgency then why
should I be able to do that so I'm just
going to to now focus on on spreading
awareness and that people in general
will start caring and realize how big
crisis okay and then and then and then
and then there you have it so she'll
deliver some more poignant remarks to
the UN like I said soon now
Greta we should mention because it is it
is relevant I think Greta has autism
she's also apparently been in the past
diagnosed with OCD eating disorders
other issues she's got a lot of mental
health issues but she has become another
mascot of left-wing activism she's been
put on this public stage given the
spotlight by the media and by her
parents even in spite of all that and
this is you know to bring up the mental
health issues it's not to make fun of
her or anything like that of course not
it's just it speaks to again this
problem I think it only makes it worse
this this this this thing that we do now
where we push kids into the spotlight
and we make them mouthpieces for our
viewpoints and we really need to stop
that especially when the kid has mental
health issues okay that's not an attack
on her that's sympathy and it's just one
more reason not to exploit her though
even aside from the side from mental
health issues even aside from that the
point still stands the way I see it
there are two problems with turning kids
into mascots for political views two
problems as far as I can see first of
all they the kids have to be put into
that position
by adults and it's not really something
they can do on their own no normal
adolescent is going to be able to get
this kind of media attention and all the
rest of it on their own they have to be
elevated by adults and that elevation is
always done for exploitative reasons
okay it's never actually done because
wow you know this kids insights are just
so tremendous that we you know we have
to let the whole world know what this
person's know it's just it's it's it's
manipulative it's exploitative you know
adults know that okay well I mean I
could go out and say this stuff and no
one's gonna pay it pay there but if I
put these thoughts and words into the
mouth of a child and do that gimmick
well now people are gonna pay attention
so it's exploitative in that way a kid
in adolescent can't really fully consent
to becoming a public figure now we talk
about consent all the time these days
and it's an important issue well where's
the consent here when you're you know
there's a reason why we say the age of
consent is you know it varies but 17 18
or whatever is agent consent there's a
reason why we say that and it doesn't
just apply sexually it's just the idea
is as a as a kid you don't really have a
full concept of the consequences of
actions you can't really you can't see
beyond the nose on your face you can't
really see you can't you can't quite
plan it all out like okay I'm gonna do
this and that's going to lead to this
that that kids aren't really able to
make those calculations which is why we
say that they can't they can't do things
like vote they can't buy guns I can't do
stuff like that and that's also a reason
why I think we shouldn't put them on the
public stage because there's a lot that
comes with it scrutiny and criticism and
backlash all that they're not gonna be
prepared for it yeah they'll love the
attention but they don't they don't
understand what comes with it and
they're not gonna be prepared for it
second here's the thing I'm a 33 year
old adult man I am 33
right or am i 34 I'm 33 this is usually
where I asked my wife you have no money
you have no idea how often I ask my wife
how old I am anyway and often times I'm
wrong I'm afraid to say so I am probably
around 33 years old I'm an adult man is
the point I've spent my adult life you
know like many adults I've learned and
I've thought about things and I've
studied issues not to mention I've been
living and I've been gaining experience
and I've been maturing hopefully to some
extent now granted there are adults who
don't really do any of those things but
many of us have and as those of us who
were in that position of being basically
mature adults who have learned and
thought and studied and so on those of
us in that position we well I can only
speak for myself I suppose I have really
no interest in the viewpoint of a child
I mean I'm interested in my own kids
ideas and thoughts and everything
because they are my kids and I want them
to develop their ideas and all that and
share it with me so I do care about it
in that sense that's all good and my
point is maybe I should put it this way
the political and ideological insights
of children don't interest me I don't go
to kids for insight especially in the
politics ideology philosophy science you
know those kinds of things I don't I I
don't go to kids for that I'm not going
to with to a 15 or 16 year old girl to
find out about that I'm just not because
they don't know anything you know they
haven't done the work yet and that's not
their fault they're just not old enough
they can't have done it they can't have
thought about these things for very long
because they just haven't lived that
long so I mean that's why I'm not going
to a kid to learn about the world a kid
isn't going to teach me things about
science and politics and whatever else
and I certainly don't want to hear
lectures from kids so whether its
climate change or guns or whatever to
hear the teenagers of the dial you
adults have you adults haven't done
anything now you're gonna listen to me
oh shut up I mean what you know
anything yeah you don't I mean and
that's again it's not a knock on kids
just your I was the same way when I was
16 and when I was 16 yeah I thought that
I could tell her yeah you listen up to
me okay I know what's going on here
yeah I thought that too when I was 16
every sixteen-year-old does but you know
then you grow up and you get some life
experience and you figure out that okay
I was actually ignorant as hell and
that's why and I I feel bad having to
make these points about kids you know I
think but this is the it's not my fault
people have put kids in a position where
they're up there you know lecturing and
so it becomes necessary this is this is
you know so I am now part of the
backlash that these kids have to deal
with and I wish they didn't have to deal
with it I wish they weren't put in that
position to begin with but here's what
I'm not gonna do and and this is why
people use kids like human shields like
like ideological human shields because
the idea is if a kid is up there saying
okay we need to confiscate guns or we
need to call carbon tax or green new
deal or whatever the kids saying it well
then you you have to just at a minimum
you have to remain silent if you don't
like it but really you have to agree
because otherwise you're attacking a
child and how dare you well I'm not
gonna play that game okay if you're
putting a 16 or 15 or 12 year old up
there to tell me things that I disagree
with I'm gonna say I think you're wrong
and I'm also gonna point out that you
don't know what you're talking about
I'm sorry I'm gonna say that I mean it
just because you put this you you you
put these thoughts into the mouths of a
child doesn't mean I have to agree all
of a sudden that games not gonna work
and if the if the child ends up with
hurt feelings or whatever that's your
fault for putting them in that position
okay I have kids myself I don't you know
I get up here myself
and I say my own thoughts out of my own
mouth and so if you don't like it then
you
you tell me that I'm a horrible
monstrous evil person and I hear that
all the time
okay and I can take it I don't put these
thought I don't have my kids get up and
speak for me I don't do that and if I
did whatever abuse they suffered it
would be my fault
me it would be on me for putting them in
that position and not just having the
guts to stand up and say myself you know
I I have never once in my life heard a
political opinion from a child that made
me go oh wow I never thought of it like
that huh we have you have you in your
entire life have you actually heard a
political opinion or an opinion on world
issues from an adolescent that made you
that actually changed the way you
thought about things or informed you of
something you weren't aware of because
if so then that either that was an
utterly brilliant genius savant sort of
prodigy of a child which is unlikely or
you're kind of stupid I mean if you're
blown away by the the ideological
political insides of a child it again it
could be that that's a really brilliant
job or you you you might just be a sort
of stupid person that you that that a
child can impress you in that way you
could go either way is that something I
don't know there are there are prodigy
children out there but most of the ones
I of all the kids that have been turned
into political mascots I can't I don't
think any of them fall into that prodigy
cat I can't think of one that has and by
the way this is this is something that
people do on both sides of the aisle I'm
not going to sit here and pretend that
this is something only the left does the
left does it with with with gun rights
typically with climate change but the
right does it too
you know there have been and there still
are kids like high schoolers and middle
schoolers and younger who the right has
elevated into
sort of thought leaders on the right
even now as we speak and it's it's it's
ridiculous it just is I mean yeah you
know there there are there on the right
there are kids with like massive
social-media followings and all they do
is give their political opinions and
there are adults who follow them because
they want to have access to these kids
insights every day and any time one of
these kids comes along I always go and
say okay well maybe this is a prodigy
brilliant genius child but and then I
listen to what they have to say okay no
they're not they're just saying this is
just a kid
we're just saying things alright um what
else well but but then then the other
part of this thin burg thing is the fact
that she came here on a sailing yacht
and so now we're being told hey maybe we
all should use be using sailing law
yachts because it's because it's it's
green friendly or whatever there was a
camera butch outlet but there was some
there was a headline say yeah Greta
Greta foon Berg came here on a sailing
yacht should we all be doing that or yes
let me go grab my sailing yacht for my
fleet of yachts let me go have my Butler
you know go go and and well I don't know
who you have under your staff that gets
your senior yacht for you but I mean
we've got to go ahead down to the marina
okay and and grab my sailing yacht yeah
I hadn't thought it I mean usually when
I have to get somewhere and it's more
than eight hours away by drop by car I'm
gonna I'm gonna fly coach but it's
because I just had never thought to get
on my sailing yacht which I have which I
just have sitting there you know
collecting barnacles all right um what
else has gone up well on a very
different note here's a clip from pink
news talking about the plight of
non-binary lesbians because I know you
were wondering I know you got up this
morning thinking what's going on with
nine non-binary lesbians
how are they doing well turns out not
very well they are in fact very upset
and they're gonna tell you about it
watch this my friends a day that I am a
non-binary lesbian charm tour tour I
identify as non-binary I'm lesbian and I
prefer the pronouns they then as far as
I'm concerned my understanding of my
gender and my understanding of my
sexuality are very much intertwined and
linked like they are one and the same so
can you be non-binary and lesbian this
is something I often get asked because
when you identify as a non-binary you're
saying that you're not female and if
you're not female and you're attracted
to women does that make you a lesbian I
think it's sort of disingenuous to claim
that you can't be both non-binary and a
lesbian because you can definitely have
an authentic lesbian experience as a
non-binary person because at the end of
the day they are terms they are
linguistic tools used to describe an
experience that already exists so you
just someone telling me that I can't be
a non-binary lesbian doesn't mean
anything because I already am one and
I'm just using the language that I have
available to me to describe that so my
personal experience with the lesbian
community since coming out as a
non-binary has been rather dismal a lot
of lesbians that I've encountered
especially on dates haven't accepted my
identity as something that they are
interested in dating or accepting to the
point where some women have wanted me to
use my birth name which I feel very
uncomfortable to use because they want
me to be more of a woman rather than
someone who identifies in the middle so
that almost bullying me out of my own
identity which is quite frustrating I
have had people say that you can't be
both non-binary and a lesbian but I do
think that comes from a flawed
understanding of what lesbianism as an
identity means both now and historically
so what does lesbian is a mean that's
not a question I thought I'd be asking
today but that's the question posed in
this video I did look it up in the old
dictionary just to be sure and because I
thought I knew and so I looked it up
just be sure and yeah sure enough here's
the definition I found sexual it's
action or sexual activity between women
between women this is the definition of
lesbianism to be a non female lesbian is
that a contradiction in terms it is
literally like claiming to be a married
bachelor a bachelor by definition is an
unmarried man if a man is married it
makes no sense for him to identify as a
bachelor now many married men
unfortunately do in effect identify as
being unmarried but that doesn't change
the fact that they are married just as a
vegetarian is by definition someone who
doesn't eat meat so to identify as a
meat-eating vegetarian
makes no sense I mean you can say the
words yes you can say those words and
you can demand that we all nod in
approval and in with understanding with
feigned understanding when you say it
yeah but it doesn't it still doesn't
actually really mean anything it's
nonsensical you can say that your left
hand identifies as your right hand fine
you can say that but it's still your
left hand your left hand by definition
cannot be your right hand in fact you
could define left hand as the hand that
is not your right hand I mean that could
be a definition of left hand for for
humans anyway so none of this means
anything and what we see here again on
the left is that the left is waging of
war not just on science because I we
shouldn't understate this oftentimes
when I've talked about this I'll say oh
the left's waging a war on science the
way that you wage a war on truth they're
waging a war on morality and all of that
is true but it's it's even deeper than
that they're waging a war on logic
itself that's what's at stake here
so more than claiming you're non-binary
or lesbian that's yeah it's anti science
yeah it's it's deranged on them in many
ways but it's simply illogical
the left wants to do is they want to
destroy logic which is a which is a
basic capacity of human consciousness
it's it's one of the things that makes
us human
arguably it may be the number one
defining facet of human beings is that
we're capable of logical thinking which
is what sets us apart from every other
known creature in the universe and the
left wants to to break that down because
that's that's what's going on here all
right one other thing this is horrific
and disgraceful at many levels there was
an incident in Georgia
I believe in Georgia the country yeah
Georgia the country not that not the
state where a woman just randomly
stabbed a young boy in the face with his
parents standing there and then went
back and tried to attack the boy's
sister and again it's it's the actions
of the parents or the lack thereof that
to me makes this especially notable
here's a video of it it's not graphic
but but it is upsetting as you can
imagine but here's the video okay I just
I don't get this why is the father just
standing there I I cannot comprehend
that and on top of the fathers of the
mother standing there there's there's
other adults in the street we're just
watching this happen but specifically
the father you know they say there's
never any reason to hit a woman well
well there is sometimes and here's one
of those reasons so there is at least
one reason the father should have put
that woman on the ground hard disabler
take the knife away put her on the
ground make it hurt for good measure and
steady just stands there he makes one
feeble attempt to you know go after her
and then and then runs away scampers
away when she turns toward him you know
this is this is pitiful I don't want to
do the thing where we take this one
incident and say oh what's wrong with
men that
based on this one this is just one guy
and I do think that well not just one
guy there are other guys there so the
businesses this is one incident I think
that if this had happened in certain US
states it like Texas for example it
probably would have gone differently but
not in all US states but it does feel
symptomatic of something it does seem
like 50 or 60 years ago there's probably
nowhere in the world where a woman you
know an overweight woman could just
stroll up to a child with her father's
with his father standing up stabbed him
in the face and walk away unharmed it
feels like 50 or 60 years ago that
probably couldn't have happened anywhere
in the world and now there are large
swaths of the world where probably it
could no that's that's one of those
scenarios where you know the man needs
to step up even if it is a woman and and
this I've I admit I I have been one of
those people in the past who have said
who's never any reason to hit a woman
never hit a woman under any
circumstances I've said that myself it's
just it's just kind of a slogan or a
mantra that we say and the idea in in
principle what we're trying to
communicate especially if you say it to
your son or something what you're trying
to communicate is we're you know women
as men we're supposed to protect women
we're not supposed to use our our
aggression and our strength to abuse
them you're trying to teach
chivalry that's the idea but of course
the blanket statement that you can never
hit a woman is completely ridiculous and
I realize that at some point you know
the last time I said it I had to stop
and think wait a second is that never
there's never a scenario where you could
hit a woman of course there is and for
instance if she's stabbing your child in
the face there's an occasion definitely
you can hit her and you should hard or
if she's trying to stab you now if
you're protecting yourself or a loved
one if it's an act of self-defense then
yeah you can absolutely hit a woman
definitely and again you should actual
not even you can but you should
basically whatever I mean really what it
comes down to is any most in in most
scenarios where it would be okay to hit
a man it would also be okay to hit a
woman because most of the scenarios
where it's okay to hit a man are
scenarios of self-defense same cut if a
man is trying to stab your child then
you hit the man it doesn't the Jen in
that scenario the gender doesn't make
any difference you're not gonna stop and
think well hold on a second uh but I
mean think you know she has she has
female sexual organs therefore no you're
not gonna make that calculation this is
a threat to your child and you are
responding to it period she doesn't get
any special treatment so in most of the
scenarios I think that's what I even
though I've said this I realize that no
I this couldn't be more wrong actually I
mean if the idea of saying never hit a
woman is to treat women with respect
then great but just say that right it's
just we should treat men with respect to
so it's there's no there's nothing
special there I think the only
difference is and I say this because I'm
an old-fashioned person probably doesn't
surprise you learn that
and so I I do think that on a man-to-man
level sometimes it can be appropriate to
use physical force against a man even if
it's not an act of physical self-defense
I think there could be man-to-man
moments where a man disrespects you says
something to you you know and it's just
I - I and so you can respond physically
now it might not be prudent
depending on the situation cuz depending
a situation you know who knows
especially these days you can go to do
with the way we react to these kinds of
things these days like in school you
know you you kids could get expelled for
just one punch in the head and it didn't
used to be that way so prudence may
change that but in principle I think
there are occasions where man-to-man men
can respond that way to each other as
men I would say that responding
woman physically responding to the - to
a verbal assault from a woman physically
from a man is always wrong whereas on a
man-to-man level it might not always be
wrong but physical if you're being
physically attacked it doesn't matter
the gender of the person you have every
right to defend yourself and
responsibility and if it's your child
certainly that's even more the case all
right
let's move on to emails Matt wall show
at gmail.com at well show gmail.com this
is from Kendall says hey Matt I'm a big
fan of the show although admittedly the
Matt wall show was the last daily wire
podcast I subscribe to how dare you to
be fair it is now my favorite okay
well you're good you're cool during your
absence i refresh my podcast screened
regularly hoping your face would pop up
with fresh content if for no other
reason just to let me know you were
alive I feared the worst the second torn
Achilles your wife going to labor early
or perhaps you are so fed up with the
current political and cultural climb in
America that you quit it was a trying
time I am elated that you are back and
talking about Liz Oh Taylor Swift and
all that is wrong with popular music
these days while I agree that the vapid
self-absorbed and morally corrupt lyrics
of today's popular music are
mind-numbing and egregious in their lack
of substance there are still real
genuine artists putting out quality
content and getting notice for it you
don't strike me as a fan of rap music
but there is a rising artist called n F
that is speaking truth and creating
introspective thoughtful music free from
but flashing and self aggrandizing check
out the link below to some of his music
yeah I actually didn't I didn't even
click on the link so I can't play that
for you but I am familiar with NF I've
heard a couple of his songs now yeah
this is a rapper this I believe is a
Christian technically a you know a
Christian rapper right I've heard a few
of his songs the one song the search I
guess probably is his most most well
known I think it's a good song I think I
and he here's what I'll say about him as
a Christian artist and what really sets
him apart and before I get there so I
listen that song I liked it hurt a few
others I wasn't big on his other songs
they weren't terrible they just thought
you know they got a little bit
repetitive after a while in my opinion
but I do think he's very talented and
that's the thing as a Christian artist
here's what I like about him even if I'm
not even if I'm not crazy about all of
his songs what I like about him is
number one he's got real talent not just
talent for a Christian artist but real
actual talent he's got a relevant sound
okay so it doesn't sound like you're
listening to something from 1993 it
doesn't sound like you're listening is
something that would would would be most
at home at a you know Christian youth
conference it just sounds relevant
current you know with it all that and
but here's the main thing that I like
about this guy that you know and I wish
more Christian artists would do I've
been I've been preaching this for years
he's making music from what I and I'm
not an expert on it but it seems like
not all of his songs are about Jesus in
fact it seems like most of them aren't
right many of them aren't he's talking
about other things just because he's a
Christian making music and he wants to
make music that is edifying and good and
wholesome and and and you know not not
as you say but flashing and
self-aggrandizing it doesn't mean that
literally every song has to explicitly
be about Jesus and every single chorus
has to be praise Jesus praise your name
you're wonderful and nothing wrong with
songs like that but you you can talk
about other stuff there there's so much
in life to talk about there are so many
things a and as Christians we experience
other things I mean in your own life is
is that is that the only thing you ever
talk about is the Bible in Jesus you
talk about you you experience other
things and so Christian artists should
talk about those other things too why
make a song about love about about you
know about heartbreak about loss about
this this one song the search I think is
kind of about his mental health
struggles that's a real
thing talk about it you don't have to
throw in a praise Jesus just just to
cover the bases gee and Jesus was ok
with that he's not gonna be offended he
can deal with it he's fine with it
there's nothing in the Bible saying that
every single conversation you ever have
must Center explicitly and directly
around me it's not in there
Jesus is not an egomaniac in that
respect or in any other respect so
that's what I really like about and I
and I just again I Christian artist the
you this used to be I mean you go back
through the ages and you think about
great Christian artists not just musical
artists but novelists painters sculptors
yeah a lot of their stuff was was
heavily religious but not all of it they
told stories and they dealt with real
things in life and they did it in a way
that would point you back to the truth
and to goodness and to light but it
didn't have to be so explicit all the
time so yeah good stuff there from Dan
says Matt I staunchly disagree with you
you should be advocating for this woman
to get on the field talking about the
female field will kicker then she can
prove herself that she does not belong
there it may result in her getting
seriously injured but if she's signing
up for an NFL team that's what she's
signing up for why not let let these
people have what they want and then deal
with the real consequences of it yeah
look I understand that attitude but I
just I don't want to see a woman get
killed on an NFL field I don't want to
see it I don't want it to happen I don't
want to see it if it did happen my first
reaction isn't gonna be see I told you
so
it would be a terrible thing I just so
yeah I think at a certain point within
in some ways feminists have to be sort
of hoisted on their own petard and and
made to realize the flaws in their but I
don't want to see people get hurt and if
you put a woman on it on the field with
NFL players she will get very very hurt
and I would prefer I prefer if they
could learn their lesson before that
and so with that doesn't need to happen
from Rachel says Oh Matt superior of the
bearded superior of the bearded race and
Redeemer of Catholics against the shame
of Michael Knowles if I am forced to sit
right beside someone on the crowded bus
and it wasn't stopped almost everyone
unloads is it more awkward to move or to
stay there when they are when there are
many open seats not besides someone many
thanks Rachel Rachel I cannot be more
emphatic about this you should
absolutely move definitely move a
hundred percent move look at it this way
if the person you're sitting next to is
a normal person a normal well-adjusted
person they want you to move because
they want they could use the personal
space and they're not gonna be offended
by it if they're the kind of person who
would be offended by you moving then
that's a weirdo and that's someone you
don't want to sit next to anyway so
either you're sitting next to a weirdo
in which case move or do you stay next
to a normal person in which case move
because you're not gonna offend them so
either way move give yourself space I
mean III I think that we're all on the
same page with with this right at least
in America I mean this is America in
America we value our personal space we
don't want to be too close to anyone we
like having our space in America now in
other countries they have different
ideas about personal space that's just
one of the many reasons why I'm glad I
don't live in any other country in this
country always err on the side of giving
someone personal space if you're asking
yourself should I give them space or not
give them space just like if you're
asking yourself should I make awkward
small talk right now or just state or
store just shut up and let them sit
there in silence just shut up and let
their blood them be in silence
always err on that side in my opinion
always err on the antisocial side in
every scenario at least that's what I
would prefer for you to do as an
antisocial person myself I was on a
plane recently and a few months ago and
it was you know I was sitting on the
window seat someone was sitting in the
middle seat and then
the door shut nobody shows up to sit in
the aisle seat and this is where the
person the middle seat moves over so
that we all have more space but this guy
i sat there assuming he would move and
as the minutes went on and progressed I
began to panic in my head thinking this
guy is not moving he's actually gonna
sit there's a three hour flight
this guy's gonna sit in the middle seat
next to me when he doesn't need to and
there's a seat there now it's awkward
for me to have to say hey buddy can you
get your butt up and move you weirdo
it's awkward for me to have to say that
but out of it eventually as we you know
started making our way down the tarmac
and I realize like this guy's just gonna
sit here and then it started to freak me
out I start thinking I need to get an
Air Marshal I mean why is this guy what
is he doing why does he want to be so
close to me so then eventually I had to
say I tried to be as diplomatic as I
could be but I tried to say hey you know
you got that seat next to you did you
want to you know did you want to just
you know go that way over there not next
to me and and he did move but he gave me
kinda it was a kind of a pause and he
looked over as if he hadn't noticed the
seat was empty which I don't believe and
then he looked at me and he said oh okay
and he gave me kind of a I detected a a
thing where he kind of looked as it was
a very brief sort of I role but that was
a disturbing that was just a disturbing
and traumatizing event so anyway
definitely move finally let's see we've
got a couple here okay this is one is
this is another one on social etiquette
from leo says hi Matt am I wrong to be
pissed off at people who use FaceTime in
public no leo
you are not this is another thing I mean
this I could do a huggie to 45 minutes
on this maybe I'll do a whole show on
this because this has become I in my
maybe it's just my imagination but it
seems like over the last few months it's
gotten so much worse every time I go to
a coffee shop now or I sit down at a you
know I travel a lot so I I do a lot of
eating alone and sitting places alone
which I enjoy again as an antisocial
person so maybe I notice it more I don't
know
but whether you had a bar you're sitting
in a coffee people are just sitting
there like they've got their phone
propped up and there and you know
there's someone on FaceTime they just
have their pal with them sitting at the
table talking to the person that is not
okay if you if you really need to talk
to someone who isn't physically with you
then you get on the phone and you talk
to them we don't need to hear the other
side of the conversation
and before you say well what's the
difference what if I had the person
sitting physically there with me what's
the difference there's a big difference
first of all the guy's louder it's just
a different tone it's more obnoxious
than it would be if he was sitting next
to you and also again I mean do you
really need that whoever that person is
do you really need to see them while
you're talking to them if you need to
see them that badly then go get in a car
and find them and talk to them no using
FaceTime in public is absolutely and it
goes to that saying when I am dictator
of the world there will be immediate
executions it will not you won't be
arrested there won't be anything it's
just you're done that's all I'll make it
quick
depending on what kind of mood I'm in
we'll leave it there thanks everybody
and and have a great weekend
talk to you next week Godspeed the Matt
Walsh show is produced by Robert
Sterling associate producer alexia
Garcia Del Rio executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Donovan Fowler audio
is mixed by Mike Cora Mena the Matt
Walsh show is a daily wired production
copyright daily wire 20 19 if you prefer
facts over feelings if you aren't
offended by the brutal truth if you can
still laugh at the nuttiness filling our
national news cycle well tune on into
the Ben Shapiro show or you'll get a
whole lot of that and much more
we'll see you there
[Music]